[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Rick and Morty season 4
episode 6 video it was a non-stop train
literal and metaphorical train of
references so we'll break it down way
more references than a normal episode on
purpose though if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes will do a Rick and Morty
merch giveaway - all you have to do to
enter just be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the episode on
the video careful for spoilers if you
have not seen the episode yet will do
top 10 WTF and Easter eggs as we go
along even though this should be like a
top 50 I'll try to cram these into
different vignettes as they go through
the episode starting with number 10 the
title of the episode the episode was
titled never Ricky Morty which is a
reference to the movie neverending story
which most of you probably seen about a
boy who has to create new story in the
real world in order to keep the fake
universe inside a book alive there were
a couple examples of this happening in
the episode people's beliefs keeping
worlds or universes alive or in the case
of Morty jumping the shark on purpose in
order to escape the stories simulation
as Rick tells them to start spitting out
terrible story ideas so the show used
the episode to make fun of themselves as
writers while referencing almost every
single twist and major moment that the
show has ever had that's why you saw the
collision of things like birdperson
happening separately from phoenix person
and Tami's snuffles all the meeseeks
evil Morty coming back and so many other
things from earlier episodes so I'll
point them out as we go along through
the episode but I saw a couple people in
my timeline that were confused on why
they were doing things this way the
episode was supposed to be about bad
stories on purpose in the most meta way
possible but the writers were also
making fun of themselves and Dan and
Justin like later in the episode when
Rick talks about the story episode
getting too meta breaking the fourth
wall saying that they would have done
interdimensional cable instead if they
wanted to get so meta he broke the
fourth wall a couple times during the
episode big shout out for the virus in
real life nobody's out there shopping
with this virus the actual credited
writer on the episode Jeff loveness said
in his own words that the episode is
about being trapped in the narrative
choke of capitalism the broken worlds we
escaped through love
in paul giamatti zaps which morty has a
really really gross name for in the
episode also this writer is also
probably leaving the show because Marvel
just hired him to write Ant Man 3 so if
you're a fan of the Marvel stuff Marvel
movies Disney Plus series there are
actually a couple different former Rick
and Morty writers that are working on
new Marvel projects for the next couple
of years
Dan Harmon himself also helped out on
the Doctor Strange movie punching up
some of their really meta multiverse
stuff but number 9 the episode starts
with the Infinity story train flying
through space the train itself is a
reference to the Cartoon Network show
infinity train which is an anthology
series about a girl traveling through a
train with different rooms that test her
before she can return home it's also
kind of a parody of the Infinity Train
episode of Adventure Time the dungeon
train that Finn gets trapped on when he
has this existential crisis and he goes
through room by room and Jake has to
shake him out of his funk in order to
get him to come back to the real world
Rick and Morty sort of takes this
concept to the enth degree using every
single story device character twist in
previous episode of Rick and Morty the
tickets please man with the sick abs is
voiced by Dan Harmon he's kind of a
parody of the Indiana Jones The Last
Crusade tickets please scene they bring
that joke back around a couple times
through the episode the bar is a very
Star Wars Cantina looking style bar each
room on the train just represents a
different challenge a different story
device in a different group of
characters but they all start colliding
by the end of the episode the person's
perspective that we take is revealed to
be Rick in disguise who later meets
Morty also disguised separately as a
woman who were trying to find a way to
escape the Train the real villain of the
episode is actually capitalism according
to the writer that was what that intact
scene was about about Morty buying stuff
buying the Train go out and buy Morty
nobody's buying anything because of this
virus within the episode though Paul
Giamatti plays the villain who's an evil
conductor who's kind of a parody of the
fandom and people yelling at Dan and
Justin about what the story of the show
should actually be within the episode
though he's trying to quote-unquote
break the fifth wall by stealing all the
narrative potential from Rick and Morty
stealing the show from them effectively
who were later revealed to not even be
the main versions of Rick and Morty
because this is all happening in
a simulation which is another reference
to the inception episode with the
simulations within the simulations we'll
get to that twist in a second too but
remember that every single part of the
episode was made to reference some
earlier episode so that's why everything
seems so familiar as they went through
room to room that's why when he sits
down at the bar you noticed the snake
tap in the bug face it reminds you of
the snakes from season 4 episode 5
smooth snake jazz and then crumb Bop
ulis Michael's head here with this other
tap the man that Rick sits down next to
is voiced by Clancy Brown whose voice
characters before on the show there were
a ton of big celebrity guest stars
during the episode he sets off the first
fake premise everyone on the train is
heading to destroy Rick the man in the
white coat because he wronged them
somehow Rick who regularly calls out
story tropes in episodes calls them out
for it what are we taking turns telling
stories like we're little girls that a
sleepover party
Rick's many arms and three butts that he
uses to fart reply to him is just the
writers referencing all the burps and
farts oaks that Rick always has and even
though this is Rick in disguise sitting
at the bar here the person voicing this
character before he changes back into
Rick is actually nolan north number 8
the next section of the train that he
goes into is christmas-themed it turns
into a reference of an earlier episode
from season 3 the one where rick and
jerry made a temporary truce but because
jerry was still separated from beth he
refuses to let jerry inside the house at
the end of the episode goobie winds up
standing outside in the cold all lonely
just like jerry did also that was the
same episode that clancy brown
guest-starred is a separate character in
rick then runs into morty who's inside
the body of the woman who feels himself
up before changing back because of
course morty would do something like
that it's revealed that the previous
story car that he came from was one
where everybody dated rick in it's
supposed to be a bunch of different
alien women but one of them is a yoda in
the background and another one is a man
so take that for what you will he says a
lot of this stuff isn't canon through
the episode too because a lot of the
jokes later in the episode are about
canon itself the things that are
official to the show and things that are
just meant to be one-off jokes
the next vignette is rick playing with a
giant snow wolf dating an ice queen
whose romantic rival is apparently the
concept of time this woman over here
sitting at the table all
looks like a parody of Elsa from frozen
Rick starts shouting out story tropes
figuring out that the train itself is
amplifying and linking unrelated
narrative fields
that's a callback to the episode where
at the end Jerry made a reference to the
a story and the Beast or the episode
being related by a common theme in
Ricketts really pissed off with him
saying there's no connection it's
complete coincidence Jerry that's
because in real life Dan Harmon's said
that he doesn't like the idea that every
single story arc in episodes always have
to be connected to each other all the
time and feels like that's kind of a
trophy thing to do for pretty much the
rest of the episode they keep
referencing different story devices the
most famous one being the Dan Harmon's
story circle which itself is a reference
to Joseph Campbell's hero's journey if
you're a big Simpsons fan - even the
Simpsons did a parody about the Dan
Harmon's story circle if you watch the
behind the scenes of the TV show inside
the writers room you can also see them
using that they really do use the dan
Hartman story circle inside the Rick and
Morty writers room he makes his big
interdimensional cable shout out there
supposedly doing another real
interdimensional cable episode but
because they referenced it so much
during this episode I'm kind of
wondering about that now they at least
said that they might go back to that
this is where the episode metaphorically
and literally starts to go off the rails
because the evil conductor played by
Paul Giamatti is trying to use them to
generate enough narrative energy to
break the fifth wall which isn't a real
thing that exists it's just a meta
reference to the show always breaking
the fourth wall because Rick knows that
he's inside a TV show which he
references a couple times through the
episode like when he references
interdimensional cable versus doing
one-off episodes this is a big Jackie
Chan shout out the trains AI references
continuity jumping off the rails he
grabs a tank of continuity that he says
will be useful later the number seven is
revealed that all this was happening
inside a blitz and chips life simulation
game like Morty's previous episode where
he lived out that life then came out and
was a little confused about what was
real what was fake and it winds up being
the tickets please man who is
experiencing all this then it turns into
a bit of a nightmare on elm street movie
as the man starts floating in the air
getting cut in half
they call him floaty blood man later in
the episode because within the Nightmare
on Elm Street series when you
inside your dreams you also die in a
similar way inside the real world I also
love that after this Rick says that he'd
rather die than write out the rest of
this story which is a reference to the
fact that episodes are typically only
between 21 and 22 minutes long without
commercials then in another reference to
bad writing they revealed that this is
all a fake training tape being used by
guards to illustrate how to do their
jobs which Rick and Morty within the
story train hijack referencing how
nothing makes sense because they're
appearing out of nowhere
everything is appearing out of nowhere
the way the cops are talking to each
other - is kind of like their story
police they're policing each other's
stories which is a joke about writers
rooms and writers policing each other's
story ideas Rick yells at Morty for
being too meta because he watches
YouTube videos of people reacting to
other YouTube reaction videos which is
actually something that happens in real
life I also love that while this is all
happening and they're calling out all
these story tropes the tickets please
man is still alive and screaming
floating past them in the window Rick
breaks the fourth wall again when he
says they're going into an act break if
you had been watching this episode on TV
right after this they go to a commercial
break the number six come back with a
bird person vignette where he and Rick
sing a song together about bird person
flying through the air which itself is
revealed to be part of another person's
story inside another car about musical
episodes notice all the Easter eggs from
previous musical ideas from Rick and
Morty episodes like there's a poster
from tiny Rick where he's getting ready
to sing his song about being tiny Rick
there's a get schwifty poster behind him
there's Morty flying out of a giant but
there's a poster over on the other side
this is a parody of Sound of Music this
alien is a joke about the cats movie
this is one about Phantom of the Opera
this is one about hairspray this is
Shakespeare over here I'm not sure what
the donkey suit is a reference to but
there's even a poster of a meeseeks box
in the background so because this is a
musical car apparently there was a
meeseeks musical inside this reality the
number five in the next vignette it's
revealed that floaty blood man from
Blitz and chips is someone that this
alien worships is a God who thinks that
he created the universe that they exist
inside as part of this weird cult they
also believe that not having sex is
keeping the universe within floating man
from fly
apart that's more of a joke about
insoles I think than anything else after
which he immediately does it with this
woman turns out he was right because the
universe starts to collapse around them
as Morty then starts to put him out of
his misery they call back to this joke
at the end of the episode when Jesus
tries to call out to his father who
instead of being the God that you would
expect from the Bible is actually floaty
man God number four Rick and Morty tried
to derail the train or at least slow it
down by telling intentionally bad
stories but the stories that he tells
are so bad that they wind up meshing
with the other tropes of the episode and
it doesn't work the way they wanted to
they call out the Bechdel test which is
a real thing the way that Rick describes
into the episode though all this Beth
and summer stuff is supposed to be bad
on purpose I love how Morty seems
weirdly stuck on the concept of
scorpions though every different one of
his stories devolved into a story about
scorpions also inside Morty's fake story
there's a picture of his son Morty jr.
there's a whole army of gazorpazorp with
evil Morty later when they use the
concept of Jesus to completely hijack
the story number three we meet the evil
conductor Paul Giamatti story Lord
character who Rick says is a parody of
space Frasier meeting the matrix like I
said earlier in the video he's also a
bit of a parody of the fans or the
angrier fans that try to tell Dan and
Justin what the show should be doing and
what it shouldn't be doing he proceeds
to make fun of Rick and the show itself
saying it barely makes any sense nor has
any real narrative cohesion spiraling
through the multiverse with no rules
burping semi-improvised dialogue then
when he starts pounding them they crash
through the walls of the train that's a
reference to breaking story walls like
breaking the fourth ball
the first one is Marty inside the
Citadel of Rick's then Morty in the
military is a veteran then Rick is a
professor trying to create the
artificial world of the show who then
gets killed by an older version of this
same war veteran Morty who just keeps
saying don't worry it's not canon
nothing out there's Canon Rick also gets
kind of pissed off at the conductor
because they wind up blowing a bro Dolph
Winkler coming back saying that this
could have been canon meaning that the
writers Dana Justin probably won't be
bringing him back in real life for an
episode any time soon just because of
this joke number two things get really
crazy with references
when they bring back sniffles all the
dogs and their mechs fighting cats in
mechs Rick fights Phoenix person while
Tammy and summer fight with lightsabers
me they probably won't bring those
characters back anytime soon for an
episode either then the writers said
that this giant evil Morty's scene is
meant to be a bit of a game of Thrones
parody for the long night episode I
guess that makes evil Marty the night
king in this scenario who's Lee an army
of gazorpazorp
Rick's from the Citadel dressed like
Time Lords from Doctor Who and meeseeks
and Rick's only way out is to go so off
the rails doing something that Rick and
Morty would never do doing a huge
religious joke because nobody likes
those types of stories you notice all
the gauges the marketability the
likability the relatability of the story
all fall to zero and all these
characters are parodies of real-life
religious themed TV show characters like
VeggieTales as morty tries to tie the
different vignettes together from the
episode it's then revealed that they're
inside another simulation within the
simulation of the Train because all the
dials and the Train are just stickers on
a toy train that Morty bought inside the
citadel of rick's gift shop in real life
yet another reference to the inception
episode simulation within a simulation
you could also question whether or not
this reality - at the end of the episode
is real as well because Rick probably
wouldn't ask Morty to kiss him like that
the number one is the end tag scene with
him yelling about capitalism and the
real virus we're all living through
watching the episode nobody is buying
anything now because of this virus and
then the fake ad for the story train
people tried to visit this website it's
not real they're not actually selling
the story train Jesus in the episode
also tries to derail things successfully
by calling out to his father who winds
up being the floaty man there were a
billion references in the episode but it
was an episode about making too many
references so let me know if you spotted
any big ones that I didn't mention in
this video but episode 7 is next week so
of course my video for that will post
next Monday there's a Clone Wars finale
video that I'll post later today as long
as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see all those videos
when I post them but everyone click here
for my new avatar the last airbender
Netflix teaser trailer and click here
for all my Rick and Morty episodes thank
you so much for watching everyone stays
safe
I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]